the body of a man is left in a grimy
dark hallway in the bowels of a hospital
in Caracas there's no electricity in the
morgue for the fridges and there's no
room anyway so the hall will do with no
medicines to treat him family members
can only offer their presence to Hector
Bello he's unable to move any part of
his body but his head he lies here
slowly dying it is inevitable
Venezuela's health service can offer him
nothing a little girl is fed breakfast
by her mother she's brought in her food
her bedding the water and soap to clean
her and the medicine her daughter Ismael
is receiving without their family
support there would be nothing provided
by the hospital but the skills of
doctors and nurses Elizabeth has
terrible stomach pains but there are no
painkillers to give her she says the
star for excellent but at the hospital
itself is falling apart she can't eat
anything of course but she might not
want to
a nurse says that this is the best food
they've served in a month
for the past week we have secretly
filmed in three hospitals inside and
outside the country's capital the story
is the same everywhere chronic shortages
of everything
shower rooms are filthy toilets have
blocked nothing can be flushed and
nothing can be cleaned
time and again we found piles of medical
waste dumped on the floor there are no
proper bins to take it away it's not
used for anything there's only one
reason that they have absolutely no
equipment absolutely nothing of any use
just these beds so somebody's just
sleeping here occasionally
it's not cancer specialist Gabriel
Romero has decided to go public he
showed us around his hospital
the only CT scanner is broken and
abandoned in a hallway people are dying
he says because he has no way of
treating them
but we are concerned
I don't know what to do the promising
high levels in waiting rooms and halls
Venezuela's most needy wait in line for
help for treatment and for medicine and
mainly there isn't any
waiting in line is now part of everyday
life across the country socialist price
controls rampant inflation and a chronic
black market means shops simply don't
have any essentials is a five-hour line
its orderly IDs are checked and they're
brought forward to see what is available
after five hours remember it's two jars
of mayonnaise the inhabitants of a
country with the largest reserves of oil
in the world
a seething my turn to buy food is on
Thursdays this Thursday I could invite
even this even this because there was no
food to buy in my house I don't have
anything well they have good whiskey and
eat good food and milk for their
children and medicines we don't have
anything we don't have anything in this
country barrio San Blas a slum the size
of a city millions upon millions of
people live in this vast sprawl of self
built houses shacks and huts it is quite
simply staggering unemployment murder
and crime rates are amongst the worst in
the world this is the home of
Venezuela's poorest people dependent on
a state that is fading them gone has
four children she showed us their meal
tonight - one potato and there is
nothing in her fridge she earns just
over a dollar a day a short distance
away we come across ten year old
joseline her parents have gone to find
food and work leaving her to look after
one year old Joey four days that are
turning she never goes to school she
says they're mainly alone these days
I asked if she gets scared no because
this is her life and it's never been any
better than this
Joe Ramsey Sky News Caracas